j'ai encore beaucoup à apprendre de la
mer et et j'ai hâte et d'appareils à
nouveau et je prépare en ce moment un
tour du monde parle est un tour du monde
au large et toutes les terres jeu après
la transatlantique et un vide que j'ai
senti le besoin de combler le livre
beaucoup aidé pour ça et puis ensuite
j'ai vu se dégager un autre l'autre
objectif le cap horn et je voudrais voir
si si je veux si je peux le l'affronter
si j'appelle passer un peu de condition
et contre le monde quel bateau lui
toujours le même toujours celui que j'ai
le trimaran les ti cats avec lequel je
fais équipe c'est ça qui est important
il faut être soudé il faut il faut il
faut sentir que l'on forme qu'avec sa
monture et que quand connaître les
limitations connaître ses propres
limitations et j'ai fait le tour de je
crois de mes possibilités à bord d'une
moto et j'ai le sentiment que sur cette
grande distance là je peux tenter
quelque chose je peux tenter un chrono
sur les traces des grands 80 du siècle
dernier se développe
tellement de choses je vois ce que ça
m'a apporté un enrichissement à tous les
plans tous les domaines d'abord sur le
plan physique bon ben il faut se
maintenir en forme
et puis et puis là il ya la compétition
l'esprit de compétition et ça c'est
précieux et ajoutez à cela la porte
ouverte vers le ray parce qu'après tout
l'océan
c'est le retour vers les éléments
naturels
c'est le contact avec des choses celle
vrai pur et puis puis derrière l'horizon
là-bas au loin
il ya toutes ces terres enchanteresse en
sachant que la voile que vous permettre
d'y aller même si la ville vous ne vous
donne pas cette occasion vous en avez
acquis les moyens
ça apporte une certaine liberté la voile
peut vous donner un peu le vous voulez
vous sortir du complexe dit car on peut
s'y rendre on devient maître de son
propre déplacement